what is the evolutionary reason for gray hair?
Does it serve to signal anything?
Well, it actually happens I've been doing
some amateur, ad hoc research on the grayness
of beards.
I think hair color is like an honest signal
of youth.
so what happens is you accumulate somatic
mutations, and that's what seems to cause
hair to
go gray.
And the older you get, the more somatic mutations
you accumulate in your hair follicles.
So if you have good anti-aging mechanisms,
at your disposal like a good DNA repair,
protective factors, then you can stay brown,
or whatever your natural hair
color is, for longer.
And of course, if you have lower quality DNA
repair mechanisms, then
you'll get gray earlier.
So it's usually in the 30s for men, when they
start to get their
first couple of gray hairs, and then they
kind of just flip in their 40s.
But I do know some guys in their
40s who were really not gray at all.
So my father's in his 70s, yet he has no gray
hair at all! he's the same color as his 30s.
I've got this theory about beards.
Beards are very evolutionary interesting,
because beards go gray earlier than hair on
the head.
And I've seen people walking around in their
late 30s, with gray beards but normal coloured
hair.
And one possibility is that the beard is a
costly signal in men.
Not only does it artificially increase the
apparent age,
beyond their actual age (there is a cost to
having it, it's like an anti-neoteny signal),
but also it can honestly signal youth by virtue
of it's colour.
and if it can stay brown for a long period
of time, longer than it should do,
then it indicates good genes for neoteny.